If you work in a business or an
enterprise, you've probably heard the
term Active Directory or directory
services. This is referring to Microsoft
Active Directory, which is a centralized
database of everything that connects to
the network. And by everything, I mean
all of your computers, your user
accounts, any file shares, any printers
that you have on your network. Anything
that anyone needs access to goes into
this active directory database. Since
we're storing user account information,
usernames, passwords, and other
important details, we can use this
database as an authentication source.
So, if we need to log in from anywhere
on the network, we can access this
centralized database to see if we're
using the correct login credentials. As
an administrator, you'll be responsible
for determining if people can access the
file shares that they need or if they
can print to the corporate printer. All
of the configuration options to provide
that access, set the permissions, and
then assign that permission to a user is
all contained within the Active
Directory database. And if you're
working on the help desk, you'll be
using this database quite a bit to be
able to reset passwords, confirm that
people are able to access the resources
they need, and provide any other support
for the active directory
infrastructure. The core of this active
directory infrastructure is the name of
the Windows domain. This is a name that
is related to this grouping of users,
computers, printers, and other resources
on the network. If you were working at
Microsoft, you're probably on the
Microsoft domain. If you're working at
my company, then you would be on the
Professor Messer domain. On the network
somewhere is a server that is
responsible for maintaining this active
directory database. We refer to these as
domain controllers. And this is where
all of this information will be stored.
Active directory has a distributed
database that it uses. So making changes
on one directory controller will copy
and replicate those changes to all of
the other directory controllers. On
these servers acting as domain
controllers, we are running a service
known as active directory. So everything
that we see on the system will show
information about the server and about
active directory that is running on that
server. If you're working at the help
desk, you probably have this console
open most of the time. A lot of your
questions will start and end with this
Active Directory database. For example,
if someone calls in with a problem with
their computer, you may want to know if
that computer has been added to this
Active Directory domain or if they are
logging into the domain, you may need to
reset their domain password using that
Active Directory database front
end. This is the main screen of my
Active Directory server. You can see it
is the server manager. This is what
comes up by default when you turn on
this server. And there are a number of
different servers and processes running
on the system. The very first one that
we see is the active directory domain
services adds. There are also a number
of other services running on this
computer. There's a DNS service. There's
a local server service. There's an IIS
web server and other services as well.
Let's get more information about this
local server. I'll click on the option
for local server. And you can see that
the name of this server is Cheyenne 1.
Cheyenne 1 is part of a larger active
directory domain and that domain is
called
sgc.local. If you were to bring your own
computer into your corporate network, it
would not simply become part of your
active directory domain. A system has to
be explicitly added to the domain by
someone with administrator rights. That
process is relatively simple, but it is
required to have that system managed on
that domain. You can add a device to the
network using the system properties. You
can also add a device to the domain from
the settings app under the system
option. This is a relatively
straightforward process, but it is
required to have that system managed by
the centralized domain controller. This
can also be done at the command line
through automated scripting. You can use
PowerShell to also provide this
functionality.
This Windows 11 computer that I have is
in a Windows work group and I would like
to add it to my Windows domain. I'm in
the settings app. And if I scroll all
the way down in the default system
option, you'll see a link for about.
Inside the about, you'll see information
about the device name, the processor,
how much memory, and those types of
metrics. You also see a link to domain
or work groupoup. And if we click that
option, it brings up another window that
gives us information about the computer
name that we're using where it is
located on the network. In this case, it
is in a work group. And that workg
groupoup is called workg groupoup. That
is the default work groupoup in Windows.
But we would like to add this device to
the domain. So we're going to choose the
change option. And it's going to ask us
how we would like to change this system.
We're going to keep the same computer
name. In this case, the computer is
Dedalus. Instead of it being in a workg
groupoup, I'm going to specify that it
is in a domain. And we're going to say
that it is the
sgc.local domain that we would like to
join. And then we'll click okay. By
default, Windows needs administrator
access to connect this device to the
active directory domain. So, we're going
to add our administrator login and the
password associated with the
administrator account. And we'll click
okay. After a moment, a message appears
that says welcome to the sgc.local
domain and we can click okay. Windows
then tells us that we must restart our
computer to apply these changes. So in
order to connect to the domain for the
first time, we will restart this
workstation. When our system restarts,
we have the option to log in as an other
user. And this would be someone who is
signing in to the SGC domain. So let's
add a username and password and see if
we can log in. So now we have a computer
that's part of the domain and we've
logged in with a username that is part
of the domain and we can manage both of
those from our centralized domain
management
console. Active directory databases can
become very large especially in
organizations where you might have
hundreds or even thousands of employees.
Each one of those employees probably has
multiple devices and there might be many
printers and other devices on the
network as well. So, it makes sense to
organize your Active Directory database
into logical areas. We refer to these as
organizational units or OU. You can
create a very specific hierarchy inside
of this database that might be separated
by the location where somebody may be
located or you might have a different OU
for each different building. Or perhaps
your OUS are specific to different
departments of your company. You might
have a marketing OU, a shipping and
receiving OU, and an accounting OU.
These OUs become very important when
you're ready to start setting policies
on the network because you generally
assign those policies to an
organizational unit. So, if you need to
associate one set of policies with the
marketing department and another set of
policies in the accounting department,
you might want to have both of those in
separate OUS.
If you're working in a help desk
environment, then you're probably going
to run these utilities on your local
workstation. But in our example here,
I'm going to run these utilities from
the active directory server itself.
Under the active directory server
manager, there is a tools pulld down
menu. And in that pulld down menu, I'm
going to choose the option for active
directory users and computers. This
brings up a utility where I can now
access the entire active directory tree
and I can look at all of the users and
all of the computers on this network.
You can see that there are some OUS that
are the default for this domain. For
example, the builtin OU, the computers
OU, and the domain controllers OU are
all standard OUS that are included by
default on this network. The Windows or
domain administrator has created some
additional OUS. You can see that we have
a Milky Way OU, one that is named
Pegasus, and another one named stations.
And if I expand the Milky Way and the
Pegasus OU, you'll see there are
computers, printers, and users that you
can find in each one of those specific
OUS. Inside of the Milky Way OU is an OU
named SGC. And under the SGC OU is the
computers, the printers, and the users.
And if I click on the users, you can see
a grouping of users that are associated
with that specific organizational unit.
If we right mouse click on any of these
users, we'll have the option to add them
to a group, disable their access, reset
their password, and perform other
administrative
functions. And of course, if we need to
rearrange where things might be in our
active directory database, we can
certainly do that by moving things from
one OU to another. This might be the
process you follow when someone moves
from one department to another or they
move from one part of the business to
another. By moving this object to a new
container, you are now applying a
different set of policies for that
particular user or that computer. We
move these objects from that same active
directory users and computers
application. We right mouse click on an
object and choose the option to move
it. On our network, we've been informed
that Rodney is going to move from the
Milky Way SGC OU to the Pegasus Atlantis
OU. To be able to move Rodney, we will
right mouse click on Rodney's name, and
we'll choose the option to move. This
brings up a separate list of these OUS.
We're going to choose the Pegasus OU,
the Atlantis OU, and we will move Rodney
into that users folder. Now, if we click
down on the Pegasus and Atlantis OU and
look at the users, you can see that
Rodney has now been moved into that new
organizational unit. Now that we've
designed our active directory tree, we
have a number of OUS that are separating
our company into logical units. We can
now focus on applying policies to each
one of those OUS. We would do this from
the group policy management editor. And
from here we can effectively manage all
of the policies for the organization. So
if we'd like to add a login script,
modify QoS settings, or effectively
manage any part of the Windows operating
system, we can do it by using these
Active Directory group policies. When
you make a policy change, it usually
doesn't take effect until the user logs
in again. But you can force a policy
change down to a user system by using
the GP update utility. This is the group
policy update utility and you can force
it to update a user's workstation by
using the slashforce
option. Here is Rodney's desktop. It is
a standard Windows desktop and you'll
notice in the upper right is the recycle
bin icon. What we'd like to do is create
a policy in our Active Directory domain
that specifies that the recycle bin icon
should not appear on the desktop. To do
that, we're going to add a new group
policy and push that group policy down
to Rodney's computer. On our domain
controller, I'm going to move from the
server manager, choose the tools option,
and you'll see there's an option for
group policy management. The group
policy manager allows you to set
policies for any of the devices in your
active directory tree. Inside of our
group policy management utility, you can
see all of our OUS. And currently, I'm
in the Pegasus Atlantis OU. If I right
mouse click, I have the option to create
a group policy object in this domain and
link it here. It asks for a name for
this group policy object. We're going to
call this recycle bin and we're going to
click okay. This puts a recycle bin GPO
associated with that specific OU. To
modify this group policy object, we'll
right mouse click and choose the option
to edit. This will bring up a separate
window that is the group policy
management editor. And I know that the
policy that we would like to change is
under the user configuration under
policies. We'll choose the option for
administrative templates and then choose
the option for desktop. You can see
there are a number of policies that you
can configure under the desktop. Things
like hiding and disabling all items on
the desktop, removing the my documents
icon on the desktop, and here's the one
for removing the recycle bin icon from
the desktop. If I doubleclick that
option, I can see that it is configured
as not configured by default, but I
could enable that policy and then click
okay. You can see in this group policy
object that that is enabled. And now
anyone who connects that is part of that
OU will have that policy applied to
their system.
On Rodney's computer, I'm going to open
up the command prompt with a cmd and I'm
going to run the GP update option with
the force and we're going to hit enter.
That will show us that it is updating
that policy. We're going to wait for it
to communicate to the active directory
server so that it then makes the changes
on this local system. And once it's
done, it says that the computer policy
update has completed successfully and
the user policy update has completed
successfully. Notice that this change
has not been made to the desktop yet
because the recycle bin still exists.
So, in order to have this take effect,
we're going to log off of Rodney's
account and log back
in. Now, when Rodney starts up his
computer, you can see that the desktop
no longer has the recycle bin icon at
the upper left, which means this group
policy object has taken effect.
One common group policy option that's
available is to run a login script when
somebody first connects to the domain.
This can automate a series of tasks
that's in a batch file or a script and
it can run that every time someone logs
into the domain in that particular OU.
You can also have different login
scripts depending on the OU that someone
might be a part of. So you might have
one login script for the marketing
department and it's a different login
script than is used in the accounting
department. This feature is built into
group policy. You can find it in the
group policy management editor under
user configuration, policies, windows
settings, and scripts. So now we can
create login scripts that run when
someone logs in. And we can customize
those login scripts depending on what OU
they might be a part
of. Back in our group policy management
utility, let's now create a login script
that will run for everyone who is in the
Atlantis OU. So we'll find the Atlantis
OU on the right side. We'll right mouse
click and choose to create a group
policy object. From here, let's assign
this as loon script and I'll click okay.
And you can see that we have a GPO that
has been created called loon script.
We'll right mouse click and choose edit.
And from here we will find the option in
the group policies that allows us to run
a loon script. In the editor, you will
find this under the user configuration
under policies, Windows settings, and
there's an option here for scripts. We
want to run a loon script. So, we will
find the loon option and doubleclick on
that. It now asks us to add a loon
script into this particular object. And
you can choose to add it by using the
add button. And to add a script name,
I'm going to click the browse option.
There is a script that has already been
configured and is in this folder called
loon map share. So that we know what
this is going to do. I'm going to right
mouse click and choose the option to
edit this script. It asks us to open
that particular file because we are
opening it with a different user than
the original one. And you can see that
it is a oneline script. It has a net use
command. It has net use G colon. So,
it's mapping the G drive and it's
mapping it to a share that is on the
Cheyenne 1 server. This is the Cheyenne
1 and the name of the share is missions.
Let's now close out that editing session
and we'll choose that option and choose
open. It's going to add that as our
script name for this particular policy
and we'll click okay. We now have a
login script that is linked to this
group policy. And that group policy is
within the Atlantis OU. Back on Rodney's
computer, I'm going to start the file
explorer. And I'm going to choose the
option for this PC. So, we can see all
of the different drives that might be
associated with this computer. You can
see our local folders are at the top,
our folders for desktop and documents
and downloads. And we have two drives
that are currently available on the
system. There is the C colon for our
local disk and a D colon that is for the
DVD drive. What we'll do now is log out
and log back in. And let's see what the
results of our login script are. From
the login page, we'll add our password.
We'll log in with Rodney's login name.
And let's start up our file explorer
again once it finishes the login
process. I'm now going to choose this
PC. And you can see that a new drive now
appears automatically after loon. It is
our mission share that was created from
that loon
script. Now that we've got a login
script for our users, it would also be
nice if we had a network-based home
directory that they could use to store
all of their documents. This allows them
to store information on a network drive
rather than storing them on a local
system drive that's on their local
machine. This allows people to store
documents on a network drive instead of
storing them on their local machine.
This allows us to have all of our user
documents in one place, which certainly
makes it easy for management and for
backup. We'll modify each user's profile
so that we can create a single drive
that they'll be able to access whenever
they log on. This doesn't require every
user to store their documents in their
network-based home folder, but with a
little bit of training, you can get them
out of the habit of storing things on
their local drive and instead storing
all of their documents on their network
drive. On Rodney's computer, by default,
you can see that we have our G Drive
that we created during that login
script, and there's no other network
drives associated with Rodney's
computer. Let's modify the profile of
our users so that each one of them has
their own private home drive. To make
this change, we'll want to modify the
profile of each of these users. And in
this case, we'll choose the Pegasus and
Atlantis OU. And we'll select all of the
users that happen to be in that
organizational unit. If we right mouse
click on that group, we can choose the
option for properties. In this
properties page, there is a profile tab
and under profile is an option for home
folder. You can see the default for the
home folder is to use a local path. But
in this particular case, I would like to
use a network path. So I'll choose
connect and I'll choose an H drive that
we'll use for all of our users. Now we
need to specify the share where all of
these home folders will reside. And in
this case, this will be on the Cheyenne
server. So I'll specify Cheyenne 1. And
then I'll specify the home directory.
Since I'm making this change for
multiple profiles, I'll use the username
as a variable. So, we'll use the percent
sign, username, and another percent
sign. Now, if I click okay, I'm brought
back to the main screen, and that home
profile has now taken
effect. To see if this change has taken
effect, we will log out of Rodney's
account and log back in
again. So, now let's start our file
manager. And under this PC, you can see
that we have our G drive that was
created as our login script. And we have
a brand new H drive that is our home
directory on that Cheyenne One
server. Now that we've created a private
drive where every user can store their
personal documents, we may want to
consider redirecting the entire Windows
library to a network share. Normally,
when someone stores a file on the
desktop, in a downloads folder, or in
the documents folder, it is storing it
on that local computer storage drive. We
might want to instead redirect all of
those folders to a central network share
so that we can easily back up all of our
users data and the users don't even have
to think about it when they're clicking
on these Windows library folders. To do
this, we need to create a group policy
that is located in user configuration
policies, window settings, and folder
redirection. Since we're redirecting the
Windows library to a network share, we
have to think about what happens with
those files when we leave the building
with our laptop. Usually, the folder
redirection is often paired with the
Windows offline files feature. This
means there will be a local version of
those files for people to use. And when
somebody returns with their laptop, all
of those changes to the local files will
be updated with the centralized Windows
library
files. Inside of the group policy
management editor, we will choose the
option under user configuration. Under
policies, we will choose the option for
Windows settings. And under the Windows
settings, you'll see an option for
folder redirection. If we right mouse
click on the documents folder, we can
choose properties. And you can see that
the setting is not currently configured.
We'll choose the basic configuration for
this. And we'll leave the default as to
create a folder for each user under the
root path. We now need to specify a root
path for every user's document folder.
And I'm going to specify a root path
that is on the Cheyenne 1 server. So
we'll specify the server name with the
two backslashes.
We'll put in the Cheyenne one name and
we'll choose a folder in this case that
is the home folder. That home folder
will be the one that every user is able
to take advantage of. And you can see
that it gives you an example of this. So
it will be on the Cheyenne 1 server
under home. It gives an example for
Clare and you can see that it is the
documents folder. That is exactly what
we'd like. So we will click okay. and
you will see that it presents a message
that says this group policy setting will
not apply to Windows 2000, Windows 2000
Server, Windows XP, or Windows Server
2003. In this case, we're not using any
of those Windows versions. So, we will
say yes, we would like to continue. And
our group policy has now been
configured. Back on Rodney's computer,
we're going to open the file explorer.
I'm going to right mouse click on the
documents folder and choose the option
for properties. This properties option
under the location tab shows us the
default setting before the group policy
is applied. You can see that is set to C
col users
back/rmck/d documents. So anything
stored into the documents folder on this
computer will automatically be stored on
the local drive. For this to take
effect, let's go down to our search
menu. I'm going to go to the command
prompt and let's force a GP update.
We'll perform a GP update and choose
force and we'll have this update the
policy on this local computer. This
gives a message that the group policy
client side extension folder redirection
was unable to apply one or more settings
and we will need to log on to be able to
have this particular setting take place.
Is it okay to log off? Yes, it is. And
we will hit enter. Now from the login
page, we will put in Rodney's password.
We will get back to our Windows desktop
and let's start up our Windows Explorer
and see what the differences are with
this new change versus what we looked at
before. Let's right mouse click on the
documents folder, show the properties,
and under the location tab, you'll
notice that now our documents folder is
going to the Cheyenne 1 server under the
home folder, R McKay and documents. Now,
anytime we store anything into our
documents folder, it will be stored on
the Cheyenne 1 server instead of being
stored on our local
computer. In Windows, you can assign
rights and permissions for a file, for a
folder, or other network resources to an
individual user. So, we could go into
Rodney's account and configure all of
the file settings that are appropriate
for Rodney. But when you're in a large
environment with hundreds or even
thousands of people, it may not be
possible to go to each individual user
to configure individual permissions.
Instead, you might want to create a
Windows group. This group can be
configured with all of the permissions
you might need. And then to activate
those permissions for the user, you
simply add the user to that group. If
you need to remove permissions from a
user, you simply remove that user from
the group. And of course, you can add or
remove large groups of people all at the
same time. There are a number of groups
that are built into the Windows
operating system that you don't have to
add. For example, you can see account
operators, backup operators, guests,
performance log users, and others. Using
groups as a way to provide these rights
and permissions saves a lot of time and
avoids any errors that you might make if
you were trying to individually create
permissions on every user
account. Back in our Active Directory
users and permissions, let's see what
groups Rodney is a part of. We'll right
mouse click and choose the option for
properties. Under properties, there's a
tab called member of, and this will list
out all of the groups associated with
that user. If you'd like to add this
user to another group, you can simply
choose the add button at the bottom.
This screen that pops up is very common
when you're trying to browse all of the
different users and groups on a system.
Instead of presenting you with the
entire list, Windows presents you with a
search box that you can use to find what
you're looking for. Let's say in this
case that we would like to add Rodney to
a group of users that have access to
remote desktop. So if I type in the word
remote and I hit enter, it will show me
all of the matches for that particular
term. In this case, there are two of
them. One that is a remote desktop users
and one that is a remote management
users. In this case, I'd like to add
Rodney to the remote desktop users.
We'll click okay. And now Rodney has
been added to the remote desktop users
group. All of the rights and permissions
associated with the remote desktop users
group now also apply to Rodney. This
makes it very quick and very easy to be
able to manage large groups of people
that need access to very different
resources. If you're in the accounting
department, we can add you to the
accounting apps group. If you're in the
marketing department, we'll add you to
the marketing apps group. And now that
this group has been associated with the
user, the user now has all of the rights
and permissions associated with those
group properties.